good news is breaking on covet but
nobody wants to hear it
vice president joe biden struggles to
find his vice president and a football
coach is forced to apologize for
decrying a racial slur i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying eyes at
expressvpn.com
ben have you noticed that things are a
little bit volatile i mean volatile
politically volatile economically
just volatile well you may have thought
about this months ago and if you were
smart what you did is you diversified at
least a little bit into precious metals
if you were not smart
then you did not well now would be a
great time for you to think about doing
that again because things are only going
to get more volatile over the coming
years given that we just spent more
money than has ever been created by man
or god
i've been telling you since 2016 to
invest at least a little bit in gold and
to invest in gold with birch gold that
was way back when gold was 1300 bucks an
ounce
just look now gold is at a new all-time
high why well gold and silver thrive on
uncertainty
well massive unemployment resurgence in
covenant 19 a huge election around the
corner
that would be the recipe for uncertainty
so if you haven't reached out to birch
gold to diversify part of your ira or
401k into a precious metals ira or just
get some
physical gold or silver from birch gold
do it today text ben
to 47 47 47 get a free information kit
on protecting your savings
with gold sin i trust birch gold they're
the people that i trust with my own
precious metals investing they have an a
plus rating with the better business
bureau
countless five-star reviews talk to them
have them help you safeguard your your
investments they're extremely
knowledgeable
they want to help you protect your
savings ask all of your questions feel
secure
and then invest at least a little bit
into precious metals text benz 47
47 47 when you open an ira in precious
metals before august 30th you'll be the
first to get a signed copy of my new
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps
for free again text ben to 47 47 47 text
my name ben to 47
47 47 to get started okay so
one of the bizarro world situations that
we are now in
encountering is that there's actually
some good news on kovit
like there's actually some good news on
covet so what is that good news
uncovered well there's a study that is
now published in science magazine
and it suggests that t-cell immunity is
a thing so there's been a lot of
discussion about how you reach herd
immunity
with this disease does this disease have
hurt immunity at fifty percent of the
population seventy percent of the
population if it takes all the way till
seventy percent of the population
then you're talking about you know maybe
millions dead over the course of time
in the united states but what we have
seen in places like new york and places
like sweden and what we are seeing now
in florida and texas and california
is that once the virus kind of works its
way through a community
it doesn't have to hit 70 of the
community it only has to hit more like
20 or 25 percent of a community
in order for the curve to start bending
down and folks have been wondering about
this they're wondering why is that
well one of the going theories has been
that there are an enormous number of
people
who are just not hit hard by this virus
or either asymptomatic or don't get it
in the first place because they have
something called t
cell immunity meaning that their body
has these things called t cells and
these t cells have already learned how
to deal with coronaviruses
and chromoviruses would include like the
common cold so if you've had a common
cold in the last two or three years then
your body has already learned how to
fight off
possibly covalent 19 is sort of the
going theory well now
there's an abstract from a study that is
in science magazine
august 4th 2020 and they say many
unknowns exist about human immune
responses
to the covet 19 virus covenant 19
reactive cd4 t cells have been reported
in unexposed individuals
suggesting pre-existing cross-reactive t
cell memory in 20 to 50 percent
of people meaning that maybe half the
population already has some sort of
pre-existing ability
on the immune level to push back against
covet 19.
the source of the t-cells has been
speculative using human blood samples
derived
before the cova-19 virus was discovered
in 2019 they mapped 142 t-cell
epitopes across the sars covid ii genome
starts over 2 is covered 19
to facilitate precise interrogation of t
cell repertoire
we demonstrate a range of pre-existing
cd4 t cells that are cross-reactive with
comparable affinity
to cova-19 and common cold coronaviruses
thus
variegated t cell memory to
coronaviruses that cause the common cold
may underlie at least some of the
extensive heterogeneity observed in
coca-19 disease so this
answers why some people are getting
crushed by it and some people are just
having like a mild cold and then
basically
being done that's actually good news
okay that means that a huge swath of the
population
already has some pre-existing level of
immunity to this virus which is
excellent excellent news and we have
more excellent news
it now turns out that the numbers in
terms of covet 19 cases
have been declining markedly like
seriously markedly in florida
in texas in arizona the sun belt the
surge is over
the surge is over now there's talk about
maybe a second surge
in the winter but that always
presupposed that this thing would sort
of die out in the summer because of the
heat
and then when everybody was out was in
the cold
then then people would be sort of in in
their
in their offices and then the heating
systems would move this thing around it
turned out that sort of precisely the
reverse happen
in order for the virus to be killed off
by the heat you have to be out in the
heat
right so it is certainly possible and
there's good data to suggest
that in areas that don't have air
conditioning that heat is killing the
virus
but precisely the reverse has been
happening in the sun belt why
when it's hot outside in a first world
country like the united states
everybody's got central air
everybody's in the office the air is
circulating and so you actually ended up
with a surge
during the summer because people were
not in the heat so in 1918 right with
the influenza
with the influenza pandemic well the flu
pandemic was a different story there was
no air conditioning in 1918
it was very it was reserved for super
rich people that meant that everybody
was basically
in the heat all the time and he was
killing this thing well now that you
live in a modern society with central
air conditioning when it's really hot
outside what do you do you go inside
when you go inside
all the virus gets blown around and then
you get an uptick well the uptick is
over in florida it is up to the uptick
is over in texas it is over in arizona
and it may in fact have peaked already
in california
according to npr officials in florida
say cases of coronavirus are continuing
to decline an indication
that efforts to halt the spread of the
disease are working now this is the part
where
media i just i don't think that the
media are being responsible about this i
don't
there's this idea that it was government
intervention that is preventing the
spread of the disease again that
everything was going wildly haywire
and then everybody stepped in and shut
down societies again and the lockdowns
crushed the curve again that is not
right
look at the timeline okay florida really
only began
to to crack down on particular activity
about a week and a half ago
okay and the cases started to decline
last week that is not enough of a delay
if you actually want if you actually
want to see when the cases began to
decline
the answer is once it started burning
through the community same thing in
arizona same thing in texas
california never really opened and
california saw surge and then it saw
decline it was not the renewed lockdown
that caused a decline
in california so the media have this
this pre-prepped narrative that it is
locked down
that that slows the spread but that's
not what happened in new york lockdowns
didn't slow the spread in fact lockdown
may have exacerbated the spread
because everybody who already had the
virus was then locked in their house
with their elderly family members
miami-dade county has been responsible
for 25 of the state's nearly 500
000 coronavirus cases according to the
mayor mayor
carlos jimenez he told commissioners
that hospitalizations have been trending
downward in the county for two weeks
for two weeks okay listen to that
hospitalizations have been trending
downward for two weeks
okay i was in florida until a couple of
weeks ago everything was was pretty much
open
right they only shut down indoor dining
they had they had
socially distanced indoor dining they
only shut that down like the last couple
of days i was there
right around the time i was leaving that
is when the hospitalization started to
decline
so it is not because they shut down the
indoor dining the hospitalization
started to decline
the hospitalization started to climb
before they shut down the indoor dining
by the way the same thing is true in new
york
about mask wearing so people keep saying
well the masquerading is what crushed
the curve of new york that is not
correct
look at the timeline the curve already
started to flatten before people started
putting on the masks
now it's not a case against the masks
it's not a case against social
distancing
it is a case that really the only thing
that you can do with the virus is
basically wait for it to burn through
that's pretty much all we know at this
point slight delays may help in terms of
allowing hospitals to better cope with
this stuff hospital's gotten a lot
better
at dealing with covet-19 people are not
dying in nearly the numbers they were
but the the notion that it is the
renewed lockdown that started all of
this that's just not correct
florida governor rhonda sanders said i
think the trend is positive i think
we're going to continue to see
the prevalence decline desantis spoke in
jacksonville he held a roundtable with
advocates for the elderly and
administration officials to examine ways
to open
nursing homes for family member visits
desantis said he wants to begin allowing
people who test positive for antibodies
to visit family members in long-term
care facilities
he's appointed of a committee of
advocates and officials to look at other
members to allow family members
to visit nursing homes which by the way
would be a good thing i mean i have
a couple of family members in nursing
homes and they're basically isolated
it's a terrible life they've basically
been locked indoors for four months
without the ability to see other people
and if people have antibodies and they
want to go visit grandma in the nursing
home
that seems like good policy to me so
this is good news
okay we should be like right now yes the
death numbers on a day-by-day basis are
not great because death is a lagging
indicator but we should be pointing out
what we should be excited about
is the fact that there was a sun belt
surge it did not overwhelm the hospital
system and now it is going down again
and we should be pretty excited by the
fact that the case load was
extraordinarily high in these states
and the death toll was actually not all
that high in these states
i know there's been a lot of talk about
you know the evils of florida and the
evils of arizona and the evils of
of texas we never talk about the evils
of california of course california is a
democrat governed state but if you still
want to
like they experienced their surges okay
florida had its surge texas had its
surge arizona had its surge
i am now looking at the list of states
in the united states deaths per 1
million population
florida does not rank in the top 15
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18.
florida ranks 19th in deaths per million
19th
okay for all the talk about how florida
was going to get wiped out and by the
way florida would have had every excuse
to get wiped out considering the fact
that it is disproportionately the oldest
state in the union
a huge retiree population in florida but
contrast florida's death per million
rate at 345
to new jersey's at 1790 or new york's at
1686 or massachusetts
at 1256 or connecticut at 1 245.
florida is ranked 19th okay arizona
is ranked like 13th georgia
is ranked maybe 15th okay so for all the
talk about these sunbelt states that
totally blew it
they didn't they didn't okay texas is
not ranked in the top 20. texas is
ranked like 27th
it's ranked about the same as california
actually so
the the this is all good news right what
we should be rooting for
is once people have experienced the
curve then that's the end of the curve
and in fact
this has become the going conventional
wisdom so i know that you've been told
that the experts are for lockdown the
experts want lockdown they want masks
and they want lockdown and they want
heavy government hands they want now
let's be real about this there are no
experts on a brand new pandemic there
aren't there are people who know a
little bit more and people who know a
little bit less
and there's a lot of controversy in the
scientific field over virtually every
aspect of coven 19 including math
scoring as i've said before
holland does not mandate mass scoring
they don't think it's useful denmark
does not mandate math coring they don't
think it's useful sweden does not do it
netherlands does not do it right none of
these places do it okay but
i've said you know out of an abundance
of caution if you want to go to a public
place where you're near other people
wear a mask my parents are wearing a
mask when they are around
my children because my children are back
at camp but there's also been this kind
of going
notion in the media that lockdowns are
the best possible tactic dr david
nabarro
who is one of the ambassadors from the
who he said we actually should try to
avoid lockdowns at all costs so this is
now conventional wisdom
well we would in the world health
organization invite countries to do
everything
possible not to have these complete lock
downs
it's a very blunt tool that's why we've
said
right from the beginning that the way
you deal with this kind of disease
is through having a really good strategy
for finding people with the disease
testing them quickly and getting the
results to them fast
tracing their contacts doing the
isolation properly
and supporting people as you've just
said who are particularly vulnerable
okay but testing and tracing is not
really relevant in a country of 330
million people with
probably 20 million infections running
wild at this point so the real answer is
you protect the vulnerable and everybody
else goes back to work
that really is the answer here okay
that's that's just what that's going to
be what it's going to be
and the good news is it doesn't have to
burn through 70 of the population
according to
the new data basically t-cell immunity
means that a huge percentage of the
population is not particularly
vulnerable
to covid 19. so president trump said
just this yesterday said we now have a
better understanding of the virus and we
are not pushing national shutdowns it's
not something that we're going to do
so we closed it down and we're now
opening it up and it looks like it's a v
it's absolutely a v but we're not going
back to shutdowns now we understand the
disease
we understand the problems with elderly
especially elderly with heart or
diabetes
or other problems and we're able to take
care of them we understand it now but
we're not shutting down we've done
uh really very well the numbers are
looking very good by the way in florida
texas and california they're heading
down
he is correct about this he's correct
and so the media have immediately
shifted to their latest spin which is
that everybody in the midwest is going
to die no
not everybody in the midst midwest is
going to die there's going to be a surge
in areas where there has not been a
surge
and there will be some death because
whenever there is a surge in disease
there is some death but it is not going
to look like new york is not going to
look like new jersey hospitals have
gotten better at this
it is not going to overwhelm the system
i'm predicting that right now right here
okay you're not going to see
an extraordinary surge in that you're
not going to see 12 new yorks
as people were predicting like two weeks
ago okay so
why isn't that good news why aren't we
celebrating that that would be a good
thing right
why why aren't americans happy about
this instead americans seem determined
many americans and particularly in the
media and the democratic party
seemed determined to suggest that we are
on the verge of catastrophe always
always in forever the catastrophe is
coming it's always two weeks away
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact
that being at home makes you remember
all of the important things that you
need to get done and when you think
about your business there's just so many
things to get done in such a volatile
business climate the last thing you need
is to spend a fortune on your legal you
just don't need to spend hourly fees up
to wazoo
in order to make sure that your business
is compliant with all laws and
regulations
make sure that your contracts are in
order or anything like that instead head
on over to legalzoom
maybe you've been wondering about the
best way to protect your family or your
business don't let legal questions hold
you back legalzoom they've been
dedicated to helping you with the right
solutions for more than 19 years
if you're looking to protect your family
with a will or a living trust or if
you're thinking about the right way to
start a business with a dba llc
non-profit or more
legalzoom has you covered it's easy to
get started online if you need guidance
their network of attorneys can provide
advice
to ensure you make the right choices
since legalzoom isn't a law firm you
won't have to leave your home
and you won't get charged by the hour if
you can get this stuff taken care of
without dealing with a lawyer directly i
mean that's a great thing who wants to
deal with lawyers man visit
legalzoom.com today
to take care of some of the important
things you need to get done that is
legalzoom.com
legalzoom where life meets legal go
check them out right now at
legalzoom.com legalzoom.com
okay so there are a lot of people in the
media and in the
democratic party who do not want to
acknowledge that there is some good news
about covet 19 which is why you see the
media
featuring idiots wandering around
beaches in mexico dressed up as the grim
reaper this one is going around thanks
to
charles franz press the afp yesterday is
who's walking around beaches in
mexico dressed up as the grim reaper
just like that crazy guy who's walking
that lawyer
who's walking around in florida dressed
up as the groom reaper i believe that
guy was also attending social justice
warrior protest
okay he's walking around two beaches
with families socially distanced far
away from other people and telling them
they're going to die
he's telling him don't go on vacation
here i am you're all going to die
he says it's about raising awareness
urging people to wear a face mask
they're on the beach
they're on the beach this dude has a
better shot of being eaten by a shark
or killed by a bystander than people
have of dying from covid
on a sparsely populated beach this guy
was featured by ashan's france press
i mean i'm sorry this is just it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous
like the doom and gloom is insane that's
not to say this isn't a dark period in
american history it certainly is that's
not to say that covet 19 isn't risky it
certainly is
okay but can we like base this on the
data at all
you know without like the pictures of
the grim reaper wandering around empty
beaches in mexico it's absurd
but the democrats think they have a
talking point and the talking point is
that everything is terrible and trump is
ignoring it now
again i've said before and i got a
little bit of flack for it i've said the
federal response on this thing has not
been all that bad
it hasn't the state's got what they
needed asked cuomo he got what he needed
in terms of ventilators they sent a navy
ship there that was barely used
california new simmons said the same
thing inslee has said the same thing in
washington state whitmer said the same
thing in michigan
the federal government has ramped up
testing to levels not seen by any
country on earth
on an absolute level okay i mean we're
doing something like 700 000 tests a day
in the united states these are insane
numbers of tests
and really honestly like a lot of that
lies with the individual state and how
that state is administered we do have a
federal system in the united states
nonetheless the idea here is that if
everybody has a downcast view of the
united states going into the election
then trump is going to lose
it's very difficult to separate how
people are attempting to portray the
current situation
from politics because it's fairly
obvious what democrats in the media are
attempting
to do right here so joe biden for
example
yesterday he he had himself a club that
he could beat trump with so trump
did this interview with axios's jonathan
swann it was not a good interview
and trump was asked specifically about
kova 19
and he was asked about the death levels
and he said it is what it is
which is a a dumb political thing to say
but also happens to be kind of true
namely that he doesn't control kobe 19
you don't control clovid 19 nobody
controls covet 19. that is not a lack of
sympathy that's a recognition that
reality exists
but joe biden is like you can't just say
it is what it is you have to say it is
what it isn't i mean i
i guess that's the pitch here was joe
biden going after trump yesterday
i think it's under control i'll tell you
what how a thousand americans are dying
to die they are dying that's true
and you ha it is what it is
it is what it is yeah it's showing like
people dead on gurneys
saying it is what it is okay again it's
on political line by president trump but
again i don't know what joe biden's
alternative is
okay like what is joe biden's
alternative it is what it isn't like
people aren't dying i'm confused
when trump says we have it under control
we have it under control as much as it
is possible to have a global pandemic
under control does anyone have any
recommendations they'd like to make
other than a national mass mandate which
is unconstitutional
like well this is it's such obvious
politicking it's such obvious
politicking then you have bob menendez
the senator from new jersey saying that
trump's abdication is the cruelest thing
dude your state your state run by a
garbage governor
the governor phil murphy of new jersey
has done a horrible job
here's bob menendez saying that it's
trump's abdication that is the cruelest
thing really in your state you shipped
all the olds back into the
into the nursing homes with covet so i'm
going to go with your governor is a
bleep show
menendez
democrats in the senate have a sense of
urgency that's why
two and a half months ago speaker pelosi
and
leader schumer sent a letter to the
president and to
senator mcconnell saying we're going to
need more help for the american people
a national emergency requires a national
response
but for two and a half months we got
crickets we didn't hear anything
no response to that sense of urgency
then and now
uh we have uh the lack of engagement
of a robust engagement that is necessary
uh to ultimately
meet the challenge i mean look it's
exemplified by their leader
president trump when he says it is what
it is
that is the most cruel abdication
of presidential leadership i've ever
seen no it isn't i'm sorry it is not
when you say it is what it is when
people die of a disease that no one
knows fully how to control
that is not an application of leadership
it's an application of leadership when
your state is the
hardest hit state by numbers in the
united states death per million new
jersey is number one
number one new york is number two okay
meanwhile you've got idiot chris cuomo
suggesting
that president trump is determined to
keep his handicap his golf handicap down
rather than the deaths i mean this is
all just propaganda at this point it
really is
middle of a pandemic and this president
spent the weekend
hitting golf balls and bragging about
his large mega crowd turnouts and
coronavirus hot zones
no masks big crowd
but pathetic and the reality is once
again
the key is the we it's the truth my
brothers and sisters this man is
determined
to keep down his golf handicap not the
number of cases that are making us sick
should we be pushing on congress
absolutely but you know too many on the
right are playing the game because
they're afraid of him
okay i have a question what what is what
does him golfing have to do with keeping
down covet like do you want him to
like i really don't think that chris
cuomo wants trump
in the in the hospitals actually caring
for covet patients in fact
i think chris cuomo should probably stay
in his basement when he has covet as
opposed to going to his second house
when he has coveted or having his wife
on social media talking about taking
bleach baths
by the way how ignorant is chris cuomo
chris cuomo was so ignorant that he got
owned by a couple of new jersey gym
owners there are a couple of gym owners
in new jersey who want to reopen their
gym
these guys you know i i would hazard a
guest to say they are not
epidemiologists they just own chris
cuomo in this club it's amazing i mean
they just start citing stats pointing
out
that the people who are at risk of dying
from covenant 19 are not generally young
people going to gyms
and they say we are taking all the
measures necessary we're doing social
distancing
and and chris cuomo just gets i mean he
gets destroyed by a couple of
gym owners from new jersey
we have had 15 000 visits to our
facility
zero positive cases nobody's sick
you're knocking trump because
0.6 of the population right bottom line
that's a stat that nobody's talking
about it's like the flu
if you take that if you take that 0.6
percent of the population
that is responsible for 53.3 percent of
the deaths
this is a mild flu no but there are a
lot more cases
there are a lot more cases and people
are getting more sick and different
people are getting sick and get sick
with the flu
and we're getting a lot of weird after
effects with this
we've got to take it seriously but that
doesn't change the fact that you guys
may be doing the right things
okay and chris cuomo has now come back
to that i'm not ripping from because of
anything and then this guy's just citing
stats all over him and cuomo has nothing
because his entire propaganda appeal has
been trump is a bad orange man who's
very bad in orange
my brother completely blew it new york
is the greatest governor in the history
of the world and the the political
agenda is hard to miss here guys it
really
is it really is now in a second we're
going to get to how this ties into
policy
because it is fairly obvious that many
democrats are using kovan 19 as an
opportunity like rahm emanuel would say
back during the obama administration
we'll get to that momentarily
first let's talk about the fact that
going to an auto parts store right now
might not be your cup of tea in fact
going to an auto parts store ever why
would you do it you're going to walk in
they're not going to have the part you
need they're going to have to order it
online or they're going to give you a
generic part or they're gonna upcharge
you because you're an amateur as opposed
to a professional
instead head on over to rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear
like airlines do why would you spend up
to twice as much for the same parts like
say you happen to need a delphi
fg 1456 fuel pump assembly for 2005 to
2010 honda odyssey
that'll cost you like 354 bucks at a big
chain store well at rock auto that cost
you 217
rockauto.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts that rockauto.com
catalog is unique it's remarkably easy
to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
amazing selection reliably low prices
the next time you need parts for your
car head on over to rockauto.com
write shapiro and how did you hear about
us box when you buy your parts to go to
rockauto.com so they know that we sent
you
go check them out right now rockauto.com
okay so
the policies now being pursued by
democrats have nothing to do with the
data
i mean truly nothing to do with the data
the the idea here
is that we are basically going to
count on covenant 19 continuing to be
bad all the way through the election so
that we can blackmail the federal
government into paying us off
or so that we can take measures against
other cities and pretend we did a good
job or so we can bash trump
i mean because there's a serious
disconnect between
reality and and what exactly is being
promulgated by various public officials
so yesterday i want to correct an error
i made on the show yesterday i was
talking about bill de blasio the error
is not that he is a giant weirdo who
murders groundhogs and also happens to
be a communist that was not my error
that part's true
the part that i said that was wrong is i
suggested he was going to shut down all
indoor dining until june of next year he
said he was going to reopen
the outdoor dining as of june of next
year but he's made no
timeline commitment as to when he will
open indoor dining so the underlying
message which is
he's never going to reopen indoor dining
i still think it's kind of true i i see
no indicator
that bill de blasio is ever going to
reopen anything like i just think he's
going to keep everything closed but
he did not overtly say he's going to
keep the restaurants closed until june
of 2021 just want to correct the fact
the record on that when i make a mistake
i want to get it right
bill de blasio continues to be however a
communist groundhog murderer so
yesterday bill de blasio came out and he
had a couple of policy suggestions
one he now says that he's going to set
up traveler registration checkpoints to
enforce quarantine orders
in which travelers from certain states
will be required to fill out forms to
support contact
tracing efforts okay so first of all i'm
old enough to remember when chris cuomo
suggested it was uncon
andrew cuomo rather suggested it was
unconstitutional for other states to
shut their doors to new york travelers
the aclu sued and won on that basis
second if your contact racing is so good
in new york city
right now that you can bar other
travelers because everything is
basically okay then why haven't you
opened up the businesses
bill de blasio and the answer is because
if you're a democrat you have no intent
on ever opening up this stuff at least
not until a democrat
is in power right because right now you
can just keep the businesses shut down
and blame all of the republicans
in the federal government for all of
your own failures
bill de blasio also threatened to lay
off 22 000 workers
if the feds don't give them a bailout
right now what a lot of democratic
mayors are doing is they are
they've cut crappy contracts with unions
they've done it for decades they've
blown out their own debt and then on the
basis of covid they're saying you know
what let's do a couple things let's
raise taxes on our citizens again
and let's go to the federal government
and demand that they give us money or
blame the feds for our own crappy
decision making
so basically they are the democrats in
these major cities
have become your kids with the car
haven't crashed it into a lamp post
they they crash the car into the
lamppost and then they suggest that if
you don't come and pay for the cleanup
bill
well you don't know what they're gonna
do maybe they'll become a drug addict
you just don't know you just don't know
so here's bill de blasio threatening
that he's gonna lay off 22 000 workers
if the feds don't pay off his garbage
policies
we need help let's be clear the help we
need
is to make sure we can keep all of our
public services when you're talking
about safety health education
they're all on the line now if we do not
get federal support soon i'm very
worried about these stimulus talks in
washington wolf because i seem to be
going nowhere fast
my challenge is where am i going to have
the people to do this work
i may have to do as many as layoffs of
000 city employees from every department
by october 1st if i don't get federal
help well i have an idea how about you
just take all the money that you're not
using on the schools because nobody's
going to school in new york
i mean it is amazing we keep hearing
that we need more money for the schools
when the schools are shut down
you shut down the schools and they're
like i need more money man i'd love to
apply that model to my own business that
sounds great
i will provide you zero shows next week
and also pay me more money
how does that sound you sound like a
good deal that's the way democrats are
now
running their cities and it's not just
bill de blasio keisha lance bottoms
who's being considered for the
vice presidential nomination by joe
biden on the basis of her of watching
her city burn to the ground
over over a shooting that was actually
good by the cops and having her cops
walk off the job she's she's considered
a candidate for vp because she checks
the two boxes that biden is looking for
she's black and she's a woman he's
overtly said this
keisha lance bottom said yesterday
closing the schools is the right choice
based on what
based on what data is closing the school
is the right choice people still have
yet to cite any data suggesting closing
the schools is the right choice here she
is
on cnn explaining she's going to keep
the schools closed
i do believe that's the right choice for
atlanta public schools because
we have some of the highest rates in the
state right now just a couple of days
ago
with our population just over 500 000 we
represented about 44 of the infection
rates in the state of georgia and given
the prevalence of underlying health
conditions throughout the
atlantic community we have a very large
minority population in atlanta
i do think that it was the right
decision to go
online and it gives the school system an
opportunity to revisit
um how students will enter the classroom
in nine weeks okay so she wants to keep
the schools close by the way when i say
the reshard brook shooting was good i
don't mean that it was
good on like an existential level i mean
it was a good legal shoot okay a good
legal shoot meaning like when a cop
shoots somebody it's either a good shoot
or a bad shoot a bad shoot means it was
illegal that should go to jail
a good shoot legally speaking means that
the person just
is justified by law in having shot the
person richard brooks stole a taser off
two cops he then tased one of them
and as he was running away from the
other cop he tried to tase the other cop
before he was shot that was after
resisting arrest that's what i mean by a
good shoot
a good legal shoot okay it doesn't mean
good as like a an aristotelian good
shoot or a morally good shoot okay
so in any case one of the reasons the
democrats seem to be
so reliant on kovid to justify their
policies
and blame trump is because the big
problem is twofold for them one
they have a crappy candidate joe biden
is old he is senile he is not with it
i i think joe biden is just as eager as
the rest of us to learn whose vice
presidential pick is
because i don't think that joe biden has
a clues to what is going on around him
so
they're settled with a candidate who is
essentially dead which when you're
running against a volatile candidate
like donald trump is not the end of the
world it's actually kind of good for you
but
he's a crappy candidate on a raw level
where he running against somebody who is
not trump joe biden would be in real
trouble there's a reason joe biden was a
dramatic unsuccess in presidential
politics
about 97 straight times before this
particular
election so they're saddled with that
and they're settled with their own
radicalism which we'll get to in just
one second so good thing for them they
can still continue to exploit the
narrative that america is about to be
overwhelmed with coven we're all going
to die again and watch out death is is
lurking around the corner for you on the
beaches of mexico or some such okay
we're gonna get some more of this
in just one second first i need to tell
you about our most exclusive
membership tier over at daily wire all
access i'll access membership features
behind the scenes access
to live streams and discussions with
your podcast house myself included as
well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to new
daily wire products as part of that we
launched our brand new limited account
collectors edition baseball bat
in collaboration with the pillbox at bat
company only 100 bats were made they're
engraved with the individual number in
the order they were produced from one to
one hundred
now guys here's the crazy part these
bats were offered to our all access
members only they sold out in two days
so you can't get one of these anymore
which is very sad
for you because you can't do the julio
franco you can't do the mickey tattleton
you can't do the chad curtis you can't
do any of that stuff because
you weren't fast enough if you don't
want to miss out on exclusive products
and offers
you yes you you should really join all
access at the daily wire you will also
get
exclusive access to live online
discussions with our hosts writers and
special guests along
with joining all access live that's our
exclusive live stream q as hosted
every night lastly you get not one but
two leftist tiers tumblers with your
membership
so head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now
to get 20 off all access with coupon
code access
this is a limited time offer so remember
dailywire.com shapiro with coupon code
access to get 20
off your membership you are listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show
in america
so you may be saying to yourself that
perhaps the
perhaps the situation with democrats
basically
trying to ignore all good news on covet
and pretend that the southwest
and that the the south the southern belt
the the sun belt is being
overwhelmed and all this that perhaps
that is being overplayed like why are
they doing that the reason they're doing
that is one they have a bad candidate
and joe biden and two
that bad candidate is a shield for a far
more radical democratic party
so let's start with joe biden who is
just a terrible terrible candidate so
yesterday joe biden was asked about the
cognitive test so he had said earlier
that he's taken all sorts of cognitive
tests right
and then he was explicitly asked by
errol barnett of cbs news whether he had
in fact taken the same cognitive test
that president
trump took and he's like no and then he
says to errol barnett
a black interviewer he asks him whether
he has taken a cocaine test
which let me just say if donald trump
asked a black interviewer
whether they had recently taken a
cocaine test
the suggestions of racism would be in
the air
immediately but joe biden is allowed to
get away with anything with that weird
caesar romero joker smile
because he is a democrat and democrats
are allowed to get away with everything
according to me
here was joe biden being both senile and
foolish
have you taken a cognitive no i haven't
taken the test
why the hell would i take a test come on
man
that's like saying you before you got in
this program you take a test where
you're taking cocaine or not what do you
think huh
i am uh i am very willing to let the
american public
judge my physical mental phil my
physical as well as my mental
fitness
yeah how's that going how's it going i'm
i'm fully willing to let the american
public judge my father
[Music]
physical and mental health
so your narcoleptic democratic candidate
um he's he's got a problem
on his hands he's a bad candidate so he
has a couple of advantages one is that
donald trump is extraordinarily volatile
and makes lots of boo-boos
and the second is the covet situation
and so democrats are playing both to the
hilt
they have to do that because the truth
is that their policies suck okay what
we've seen in major cities is they are
they're talking about defunding the
police
they are they're watching as crime rates
skyrocket in major cities around the
united states
joe biden is not going to stand in the
way of any of that
there's type of minneapolis business
owner that was going a little viral
yesterday
talking about how they need more police
in minneapolis because
this is insane i mean minneapolis is
being overrun by criminals because
the city has basically decided to let
the law-abiding go by the wayside
then the night is no no security sure
so a lot of people try to get in inside
in the back
i stealing things in the back and
we need more police okay but no no no
that guy's probably you can hear he has
an accent it's probably because he's
like
he's internalized his whiteness that's
the reason that he's saying we need more
police by the way joe biden trying to
figure out who his vp candidate
is going to be and i think at this point
the front runner is pretty obviously
susan rice i think he hates kamala
harris i think kamala harris hates him
i think kamala like he better have a
food taster if kamala harris is vice
president
is all i can say i mean this is going to
be like lenin and stalin like one day
joe biden has her up to camp david and
the next day they're wheeling out on a
gurney like this is
i i do not trust kamala harris let's
let's put it that way in any case
susan rice is extraordinarily radical
she's been able to get away with being
extraordinarily radical because she
hasn't really been in the public eye
she's been in the public eye for
basically two things in her career one
was lying openly about benghazi
suggesting that the benghazi terror
attack was not in fact a terror attack
it was a response to a youtube video
which is insane
and second susan rice is famous for
having unmasked michael flynn
right she's famous for having been deep
in the center of the entire effort to
gin
up the trump-russia collusion scandal
those are her two claims to fame and
suddenly she's on the vp shortlist
because she's a black woman
because too many folks in the democratic
party halls of power have decided on an
affirmative action program
for the vp they're not going to go with
somebody that that may be the best
qualified she's never held elective
office for example they're not going to
go with somebody who biden is even most
comfortable with they have to have
somebody who checks particular racial
boxes here's susan rice she is a radical
she's a very radical person on foreign
policy she's incredibly radical she
believes in in basically a bernie
sanders foreign policy
here she was yesterday on defunding the
police talking about taking money away
from the cops
we have a long history of inequality of
oppression
that endures in this country and we need
the police to be
part of the solution in some instances
they are in other communities they're
not there's no one-size-fits-all
approach so i'm for
reimagining the role of the police
getting them out of
things like social work i'm for
responsible
reallocation of resources where that
makes sense to invest more in our
communities
and the health of our citizens but it
doesn't
fit a one-size-fits-all approach you
can't just
take money away uniformly and put it
somewhere else
or take it away altogether i think we
need to look at this community by
community and be quite uh thoughtful
about it okay that's a mealy-mouthed way
of saying yes she wants to take money
away from the police
and she is she's on the the mainstream
democratic side the far left
is grabbing control of this party so
donald trump said yesterday that joe
biden
is basically a puppet for the radical
left this is this is correct it is true
i mean joe biden is a puppet for the
radical left and he's going to have to
answer some serious questions
about dissociating from the radical left
pretty soon
at some point he's gonna have to answer
some questions and that's when this race
actually gets kind of interesting
remember we're still pretty early here
here's president trump going after biden
he's against that group and it's not him
it's he's told what to do he's a puppet
for the
for the radical left okay so he is
correct
about this and what is the radical
they're in the ascendant they're in the
ascendants you can watch it happening
in real time aoc yesterday said about
the green new deal that they have been
moving through the democratic cause of
power and they are gaining support for
their insane green new deal
a program that would essentially
bankrupt the entire western world on the
back of bad science
we've talked about aoc's insane green
new deal her suggestion we get rid of
airplanes and that we
and that we all take trains for some
reason and that we and that we
retrofit every single house in the
united states and that we stop using all
carbon-based fossil fuels and all of
this is nonsense it's like serious
serious nonsense
but aoc was stumping for ilhan omar
yesterday elhan omar i believe did win
her primary rashida talib also won her
primary
aoc yesterday was was stumping for the
green new deal
this lady is in the ascendancy in the
democratic party
oh you introduced the sweeping
legislation why didn't you pass it yeah
and we're like
uh we first of all we've been here for
five minutes second of
all even with with resolutions like the
green new deal or your housing
resolution
or lots of other big progressive
resolutions we've
actually been creeping towards getting a
majority of the democratic caucus signed
on board
and so a lot of people think that
there's only like two people on the
green new deal
uh no there's over a hundred members
signed on uh of congress signed on to
the green new deal
and she's right about this she's correct
about this she is the one who is now
pushing forward the ship okay and and
good evidence that this is happening
yesterday a woman named corey bush who's
an extraordinarily radical
leftist there's a person who for example
openly supports boycott divestment and
sanctions from israel it's such a
radical position that her democratic
competitor in this primary that she just
won yesterday
a guy named william lacy clay who's been
in congress for like 20 years
he campaigned against her radicalism and
he lost according to the new york times
cory bush a progressive activist and
leader of the swelling protest movement
for racial justice
toppled representative william lacy clay
jr of missouri in a democratic primary
on tuesday
notching the latest in a stunning string
of upsets against the party
establishment
bush 44 had captured nearly 49 of the
vote by late tuesday evening
compared with 45.5 for clay according to
the ap
she had tried and failed to unseat clay
in 2018. she lost by like 20 points but
this year she wrote a surge in support
for more liberal
confrontational politics within the
democratic party amid the coronavirus
pandemic
and the national outcry over festering
racial inequities now
bush wasn't running against like an
older white guy like eliot engel in new
york
she was running against one of the like
his father was one of the founders
william lacy clay
his father was one of the founders of
the congressional black caucus it's a
black man
bush's victory which came on the same
night that missouri voters decided to
expand medicare eligibility
was a significant milestone for
insurgent progressive candidates and
groups like the justice democrats that's
aoc's group that have backed them across
the country
it shows that the same brand of politics
that has helped young liberal candidates
of color unseat veteran party stalwarts
in places like massachusetts and new
york could also resonate deep in the
heartland
against a black incumbent whose family
has been synonymous with his district
for decades well first of all
trying to distinguish between like
massachu
between like boston and new york city
and st
louis that that like i'm sorry but
pretending that urban areas of missouri
are exactly the same as like the royal
heartland of missouri that's just that's
a weird weird line by the new york times
like the tr try running corey bush
in the middle of like heartland missouri
and i don't mean like in the major
cities i mean like in rural areas
like forget it bush now joins figures
like aoc who defeated 20-year veteran
representative joseph crowley in 2018
and jamal bowman who last month won a
primary against representative elliot
engel
a single mother former nurse and pastor
bush would be the first black woman to
represent the state of missouri
in congress the plurality of the
districts which encompasses saint louis
and some of its innermost
liberal suburbs is african-american and
considered safely
democratic i love that they're saying
she's the first black woman to represent
the state of missouri
yeah she's representing a black guy
she's she's supplanting a black guy so
it's not like
overcoming racism by supplanting a black
guy with a black woman like
no tonight's missouri first district has
declared an incremental approach isn't
going to work any longer said miss bush
said we decided that we the people have
the answers and we will lead from
the front lines clay who's the scion of
a storied black missouri political
dynasty in his tenth term in congress
tried to make the campaign a referendum
not only on bush's suitability but also
the progressive movement behind her
he carried out a series of dark personal
attacks by the way all attacks on
somebody's record are dark and personal
if you're attacking a socialist
according to the new york times
he describes her as a prop of
out-of-town interest seeking to divide
the democratic party along racial lines
clay highlighted his own ties to the
democratic power structure he earned
endorsements from pelosi kamala harris
of california and planned parenthood the
justice democrats won
anyway clay was not in the moderate or
progressive wings of the party
he supported medicare for all and the
green new deal
but he was he was bashed anyway and he
lost to see because he still
was not radical enough bush built her
campaign around her personal story as a
working-class black woman
pulled into public life after a white
police officer shot and killed michael
brown in 2014
she joined protesters in the day after
the shooting and in the weeks and years
that follow became one of their leaders
she was a fixture of protests across the
district this summer
she drew a bright line from her
experience confronting police on the
streets where brown's eye to her victory
at the ballot box
she says i'll be holding every single
one of the police officers accountable
so get ready this is your new democratic
party your new democratic party
is in fact the aoc democratic party and
joe biden ain't going gonna hold these
people back he is not
he is not so when the trump's comms
director calls biden's policies a
birding biden communist manifesto that
is not
incorrect and now you know why the
democratic party is so reliant
on the anti-trump and they cannot rely
on their candidate they also cannot rely
on their record because they both talk
they can't rely on their platform and
they can't rely on their own can they
can't rely on their own
body in congress and meanwhile the
culture wars continue i pay stupidest
story of the day
a tcu football coach listen to the
headline okay the headline here does not
match the story and it is perfect
example
of how dumb our moment is okay this is
the the washington post
tcu football coach apologizes for using
racial slur that is in any context
unacceptable so if you just read that
headline what you would assume from that
headline
is that the tcu football coach like used
the n word and directed it
a black player right that's what you
would assume so what actually happened
he was chiding a player for using the
n-word and said you can't say the bleep
he said you can't say the word bleep and
now he's being raped over the coals for
saying the word while explaining that
you're not supposed to use the word
i am not kidding that's how dumb we have
become as a country
according to the washington post tcu
football coach carrie patterson on
tuesday apologized for using a racial
slur
in an attempt to get a player to stop
using the word
patterson called his use of the slur
unacceptable in any context
so you're not even it's like voldemort
if you say the word
trying to get people to not say the word
you have said the word and thus you have
sinned by trying to get people to not
say the word
that's how dumb we have gotten in this
country he's taking the perspective that
no one should say the word but in order
for us to know which word not to say he
says the word
and then everybody's like how dare you
say the word it's
unreal several players on monday
boycotted practice and met with
patterson to address the incident
former defensive back nico small accused
the coach of using the word in front of
the team in a now deleted tweet
according to the ap
several teammates tweeted that small had
not included the context
they tweeted their own explanations and
several skipped practice
freshman linebacker dylan jordan tweeted
monday afternoon about an exchange with
patterson at practice on sunday in
exchange in which he said patterson told
him to stop using the n-word in team
meetings
as he did so patterson repeated the slur
according to jordan
patterson called him an effing brat i'll
send you back to pitt
during practice in reference to jordan's
hometown of pittsburgh kansas
jordan said he responded for what i
ain't did nothing
and patterson said you've been saying
bleep in the meeting room
okay so you're saying don't say that
that's a bad thing to say in the meeting
room stop doing it
it's immature and so now he's the one
being raked over the coals
man if you want to talk about if you
want to talk about the injustices of
identity politics you got a player who's
black who says the n-word
the coach who's white says you know what
i don't want that word used around here
don't use the n-word and he says the
n-word to say don't use it
and now the coach is the one on the hot
seat insane
insane patterson is the winningest coach
in tcu history
he tweeted tuesday morning he had met
with seniors and leadership council
members to discuss
how he moved forward as a team together
absolutely crazy absolutely nuts
just ridiculous that's not the only
ridiculous story of the day along these
lines by the way
i i enjoyed oprah winfrey explaining
that whiteness gives you privilege no
matter what she's only the richest black
woman on planet earth
she rose up from extraordinarily
impoverished circumstances to become
maybe the richest woman
on planet earth and she's talking about
whiteness always gives you privilege i'd
love to know
all those white people in appalachia
looking at oprah winfrey and thinking
man
man i wish i didn't have this you know
my privilege here i just feel privileged
looking at oprah winfrey who owns like
the entire island of maui
here's oprah winfrey talking about how
whiteness is always a privilege even if
you're oprah winfrey
the reason why i adore emanuel so much
is because
he is speaking to people's hearts
and understands that it really is a
heart
issue and you all are the ones who are
going to be able to
change the way your friends
your colleagues your white family
members
begin to see racial injustice and racial
inequities in this country
that's where it happens it's going to
happen at your kitchen table and in your
living rooms and in your soccer games in
there that's where it's going to happen
and your ability to have that influence
wherever you are and to speak up
wherever you are to share your heart
i think that's how we bring a bring
about change and she said you still have
your whiteness that's what the term
white privilege is it means whiteness
still gives you an advantage
no matter what no matter what really no
matter what oprah winfrey really
this is the dumb world we now inhabit
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content in
the meantime
go pick up a copy of my brand new
best-selling book how to destroy america
in three easy steps which details the
conflict of visions we are currently
watching
in the street in the meantime have
yourself a wonderful
day we'll see you here a little bit
later i'm bench prepared this is the
bench shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matt walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen
you